tonight las vegas pride will kick off
the weekend with the annual parade the
celebration just started in downtown and
that's where we find christian he's live
as the countdown to the parade continues
got the kickoffs at six the parade at
seven look at everybody behind you
christian
very colorful let me tell you las vegas
pride is all about love it's all about
fun and of course great music right
which is why so many beautiful people
are out here today both locals and
visitors we've been talking to a couple
of them some folks even coming out here
all the way from virginia they're just
so excited to be able to be back out
here in person and celebrate pride now
again that pride parade starts in about
30 minutes and it's just part of one of
many different events scheduled
throughout the weekend the parade is
taking off at seven o'clock there's a
festival happening tomorrow and of
course other after parties and pool
parties throughout the valley now
governor steve sessolack and his wife
are here they're going to be the grand
marshal of the parade along with miss
nevada so just a lot of excitement as
folks are just getting ready to see all
these wonderful floats pass by here in
downtown again the parade starts at
seven o'clock here at bridger and fourth
in downtown a fun and free parade for a
complete list make sure you check out
eight newsnow dot com christian council
is we're live local now